[Music]
alright let's go check this out guys
Emily nice can I take a look at what
you're doing with the tight posters you
do okay Aaron's gonna be filming this
whole thing and the people on the
Internet's want to know they've been
seeing your posters hanging behind us on
the show and we're gonna have you on the
show really soon
so let's take a look at this and we'll
just look at it one at a time
now what program did you use to design
this everybody else wants to know it's a
strong use illustrator I'm not in design
why do you choose illustrator it's
easier to move the shapes vector is the
best choice right for me personally okay
cool why don't I take this moment to
introduce Emily well that files reading
pulled out Emily is a graphic designer
she graduated from Art Center she was a
former in turn here and she's a former
student I've had a lot of working
experience with Emily and we're really
lucky to have her working blind and also
do some future related content so you
guys are gonna see a lot more of her and
some of the other designers around here
but today we're just gonna focus on
Emily so the assignment that I gave
Emily was to pick some of our best
viewed episodes right and then to design
a poster for each one so we can have
this style of posters that we can print
out as a mural or do something else with
it and this one was run your design
business like a boss like a boss and
okay so you're using vitória which is
the typeface and in this instance I told
Emily it was okay to break away from the
blue yellow palette which you guys are
very familiar with she just wanted a
little variety and maybe we're getting a
little sick of just blue and yellow so
it's important for us to have other
kinds of colors to work with so in case
you guys are paying attention
okay this is also futur bold and not
some other weight and the dimension is
all the same so we're going to see how
Emily takes each one of these concepts
and then interprets it as a poster
design so running your design studio
like a boss is a very clean design I
like the greyscale and I also like that
you did this diagonal cross it
connecting the B and the O and the SS
like that and then inverting it here and
kind of creating a more transparent
thing out of curiosity why did you
decide to invert this and not just leave
it a red slash or cross
[Music]
black-and-white photos I just thought I
would have like a little overlay Oh kind
of just a write-up yeah I like it I
think if you had done it already it
would have seemed like this is canceling
this out which is kind of like the
International single Ferdie
don't do this which is not what we're
trying to say so in this case you're
just trying to introduce a graphic
element so your instincts served me well
here by making it more transparent
through that thing I think it would be
kind of cool to if you take in that
strip and use that as a mask and then
offset a little bit is it offset a
little better no so if you offset a
little bit there we have it'll be more
like prismatic and I think that could be
kind of cool this is a nice design it's
super simple it's very centered but this
little piece of asymmetry gives it the
right balance for me okay good job
let's look at the next design getting
started in graphic design okay so all of
these posters your initial brief was
this is supposed to be a mural you had
thought about how all the posters would
look right next to each other okay so
all of these posters have like a certain
angle to it that's why this one if you
know some people might ask why did you
put diagonal across the poster okay so
good point right but there are different
angles because that's that's all the one
that's a different angle this looks like
is it almost 45 but not quite 35 okay
it's really close to it so that's a
really good point that you bring up in
terms of like what we're looking at you
guys are seeing individual designs
because that's how we'll critique these
right now but it's meant to be seen as a
whole they're they're meant to be
collage together or lined up in a grid
so there are certain elements that have
to repeat otherwise it'd be too chaotic
into frenetic okay let's look at this
design here getting started in graphic
design I like how you broke that up how
you inset that so this is a really good
example of asymmetrical typography and
he'll Emily knows enough about design to
make this work it's easier to look at
this thing than it is to do this kind of
asymmetrical design yet achieve the
balance and I think that's about
proportion and spacing that it's not
even and is broken up and I like that
she inserted this kind of unexpected
element in here where I'm seeing some
things here because I know I noticed
that we used a lot of the snapshot
elements quite a bit let me see your pen
and so what I'm looking for and I'm
gonna try to draw on this thing if I can
do it
so you're guys gonna see the use of the
grid right so theoretically if I were to
draw a line from top to bottom here
those things need to line up and I'm
looking for that same kind of cohesion
here so that's one where this is so
close to this I think it would have been
better if you just drop this down like
that and made it hit that line it's
gonna anchor these things together and
say that this is not arbitrary I'm
looking for those kinds of relationships
so here she has type that's justified
right but then it doesn't quite hit this
line either so I don't know if it hurts
artistic scoot it in okay or let me let
me do this draw the arrow so that it
hits that line just scoot it in a little
bit or push this farther out this way so
that it doesn't it's not closed up like
this is a little close for my comfort as
is this too close for my comfort and
another way that you guys can use the
grid is to take this sucker these little
dots move them right here and make it
anchor to the D I messed up on that line
let's try it again somewhere around
there I would these little things gonna
bother me just snapping things they're
very very minor things but typography is
about the details and once you have the
design concept and it's working for me
so that there's nothing left for for
chance like these things are nice
elements again if you were to take this
why am I just not drawing space there
and maybe you just added a little
vertical element here I'm trying to
anchor everything so there's a rhythm
and a harmony and a little bit of
structure allows the expressive nature
of a typography to work okay
let's keep going and let's look at the
next layout but good job overall
okay now you have to do a little magic
there
just out of curiosity what was the
keyboard shortcut used to fill with a
background it's a command shift delete
it depends because for me if my white
was my background color so that was
command delete it goes the foreground
it's crashing doing okay alright okay
let's look at this design so this this
35 degree angle is consistent here so
you saw that in the other design what is
UX design what is UX design so lots of
elements here ok
now let's break this design down why is
this design working ok and maybe where
can we tweak it a little bit I like the
fact that I'm gonna draw all over it and
then I'm gonna do this I like that you
can clearly see I thought on something
all over all that brush ok I like that
there's this element here and it's
grouped together with this this is quite
nice right so that's what we would
consider your primary read this is read
number one okay let's read number one
this is your secondary read this group
of stuff here right and then all these
little bits and pieces I would consider
read number three okay so that's that's
how you got to look at this design like
there's my I know where to go one two
and three and then we look at where I
travels from here let's switch colors
and I'll do something like that let's
switch colors hopefully this works
my eye goes from this to this and it
goes back out
not a bad flow and you guys need to be
aware of how your eye moves through the
design if it's creating a pleasing
movement or not okay
and so let's now go in what happened
here did I do I drew on the background
the background you set me up fourth
right you're supposed to create a new
layer no wonder wasn't working it's
Emily's fault
okay anyways alright so here we are
here's where I think it's a little funny
well before I get into like how we can
improve this I like that there's
contrast you have big bold letters and
you wax kind of separated like that it
makes it almost like an illustration and
then you have this black type let's look
at this black type here now she's
cutting things off the edge here and you
have to kind of be careful where you cut
things off
if you cut off too much we can't read it
it reads like a V you cut off not enough
and it just looks accidental I think you
could probably push this up to the right
a little bit a hair that way just to
give me a little bit more of the W and
the you just hair more and I think it
makes it easier to read next is this
part right here the U and the X I think
they could have been the same point size
because the X is a very legible
character and if it were like the same
point size
you don't need to see that much of it
and would still read okay I like that
and I like these little bits of details
so this is good contrast really big red
typeface a block of copy here and these
little kind of detail things that are
floating around and I think that's
totally okay that it's kind of haphazard
kind of strewn about I think it works
lots of negative space around this
design it's working for me okay let's do
the same bits do we need to add a layer
okay for everyone in internets what cut
what the keyboard command did you hit
they always want to know what's the
keyboard command shift command and it
gives you a new layer okay
great typography design in art direction
okay alright so whenever you're
designing let's look at this for a
minute we're looking a proportion of
this space this volume compared to this
volume and lastly compared to this
volume sorry iron so we have three
things three units of measure and I like
them big medium and small the kind of
work and this is where a less skilled
designer would probably do these two
things as the same and it makes it too
even too predictable so you have to be
aware of the space not only about what
you put on the page but the negative
space that it creates in between so I
think that's working well for you okay
see what else here you have to be
concerned about where these things get
cut off so this is really tricky so you
have like a little thing here and a
little thing here where it comes over so
we want to try to make sure that it cuts
it off in a healthy spot like here all
right that would work okay I'm not
saying this is bad I just want you to be
very mindful of those little areas let
me switch the cursor here so everybody
can see those little areas there
again I'm just looking for cohesion and
anchoring everything together it's gonna
be a repeating pattern here for me so
you see this art direction here this is
justify type so I'm gonna bring it up
here my eyes looking for something for
it to connect let me move it over so
it's actually in the right spot okay
so again now you can see that this scoot
that over a hair right so this little
element moves over and I think if you
had some lines or some dots or something
here that would also tie this whole
design together looking for things to
anchor I really like this element here
these vertical tick marks that you've
included that that show the aperture or
something I don't know what that is
that's that's what it feels like it's a
nice layout again and well done so we're
talking about very very minor things
let's go to the next one ruler command
shift and hit return assuming that the
layer structure is set up privately
let's change the background color here
to dark gray or something else black is
that gonna not like right we need more
contrast okay now you guys can see this
design okay let's look at this one this
one's a little busier than the other
ones it's using two colors again black
white and red and it's the red it's
overlaid on top of this I think that's
an inventive nice use of another color
and you're getting some color over
prints where the red and the black make
a different color but the red and white
make a different color that's a nice
print technique that you're using I'm
just looking at the little shapes that
it creates and so where am I gonna point
something out of way yeah this one is
the one that bothers me right yeah this
one's tough like the best I could do
without making the like
I don't know what to call it like these
little slivers yeah the little doodads
the the fragments that hang over if you
increase the scale of this perhaps that
will help okay so you're really dealing
with headline copy which is great and
then these all these things are really
textural so you get to manipulate these
in any which way you want right and
again I'm still looking for that kind of
flow and connection so I'm gonna just
circle some things this is a little bit
of a problem area for me it's a minor
one probably these little spots here
okay the other ones are good you get
enough of a crossover that looks good I
do not love this line that's cutting off
this thing and I'll tell you why you
have this beautiful beautiful poster
format it's very vertical and you've
essentially cut it up into three pieces
I think would be much stronger design if
you follow the same idea okay this idea
is not consistent so you did welcome
underscore to the I think you do
underscore here and then you do an
underscore before here and now if we
were to get rid of this and this it
allows the space to move throughout
instead of cutting off your design I
think that would help your design here
and I'm not sure there's alignment here
it feels like it's closed but I'm a
little suspicious it feels like it's a
little in it's kind of like really close
and I think if we zoomed in there super
tight it may or may not be right who
knows but let's just make sure I just
know Emily she's like right you've
indicated
[Music]
okay well he's I'm trying to prove a
point here more often than not when she
rolls the dice on this one she loses but
let's see all right she is vindicated
good job
Gong's she gone she okay all right so
let's hide this every time I speak
Chinese my kids are ashamed a Chinese
person cries a tear okay anyways alright
so it's important that you you're
looking for all those tangent C's that
you lay it out like this and then you
zoom in just a double triple quadruple
check okay
did you ever include any circular
elements in any or designs now it's not
part of the visual vocabulary
okay let's go
it's maybe an optical illusion do you
know what I'm going to say the optical
illusion is this unit right here is
thicker than this one but maybe because
of where I'm sitting
what do you think are these all the same
units of measure how confident you have
this one are you super cute like 95%
let's check let's double quadruple check
it feels a little off yeah I'm pretty
sure of it now I think these two are the
same let's see it
okay so let's hide that so that's pretty
much the same right if I might be one
extra pixel but let's just see and I'm
gonna bring it over here open it once
again excellent good job
Emily's batting 240 right now she was
holding her breath on that one as I'm
sitting over here off axis angle it does
look smaller to me from here and it
still looks smaller to me of course you
want to check all these details guys
because type is about the details okay
it looks like Emily's been paying
attention on this one because things do
appear to be lining up right and so you
have this Center bit and this is
centered to right this is centered to
the comp and kind of boring wait a
minute is the center - all right let's
just zoom it's all centered kind of
boring except when she introduces this
oops when she introduces this and this
it breaks up the symmetry of the layout
and I quite like that I think there are
some slight spacing issues like I think
this could go a little bit north you
kind of see that we're grouping pieces
of information so you have this space
and you have this space and I feel like
it needs to be a little bit more
balanced these are very minor things if
you were in a class of typography for me
I'd definitely give you an A or a minus
here these are we're splitting hairs
here okay but since the layout is
already really super tight that's the
only left the only thing I have to say
I'm sure people get angry happy anyways
because that's what they like to do stop
picking on Emily this is the episode
about style scapes
style escapes no I thought that was a
continuation of this s I hope so yeah
yeah okay so we got some problems here
on this layout I read like you've each
strip everything away if you can imagine
that there were no type on this white
black and white that looks like a
beautiful poster a modern art piece
right because the proportions are really
good I'm boring Scott Rothstein just
yawning right through my video Scott
thanks dude thanks for that sound effect
the typography is killing you I get it
alright anyways here's where I think
this one is a little bit funky style
escapes this should be read right so
let's go pick a red color so this should
have been red and I like that so it's
just having a little fun with our
typography that way it continues on here
we think of the page as a
three-dimensional layout and that's just
a 2d thing so when the type bleeds off
this edge we can say that it can
continue on this edge that's cool I like
that it's just missing an S here that's
all I think it style escapes right yeah
I didn't imagine that so there you go
okay the rest of this is just decorative
I like having this element here
that's let me switch back to my yellow
color okay I like having this element
here because it's a nice block thing
that breaks up this whole thing it's
also a repetition of this - hash mark -
that's what it's called - so I like
seeing kind of repetition and playing
repetitions on the theme it's a
variation who knows what this links up
to but good layout let's go the next one
now Emily how long did you work on these
because everybody wants to know like how
long do you give people time to work on
these things looking anyway
I feel like track back to my memory
roughly how much time do I give you to
work on these things two weeks in
between projects so time working on it
yeah what do you think really a week
five days
how many layouts did you do twelve
layouts you did a couple of versions
this is the final version so we could
have looked at some of the other
versions but we're just focusing on this
version right now
all right this makes me a little
uncomfortable here all right
give me a little bit more of that D and
you're good so you see like it's hard to
figure out what this letter is and you
got a little sliver there that's that's
the danger of cutting things off you
have to be very intentional when you cut
things off and this is the bar or anding
I'm not sure if you gain too much by
having that little sliver so I think one
you get rid of this and you just move to
be over that's one option
okay the other option is you pull
everything back and you see a little bit
of what makes it the are like that part
right just so that we can connect it to
this it doesn't have to be a one-to-one
relationship you can actually repeat a
little bit more of the letter and you
include a little bit more here okay I
believe you could cut this part off and
it still would read as branding because
I don't know if any other letter that
would read with that mark okay it's
almost like you got to either give me
more give me less cuz this little bit
just a little sliver here bothers me
okay
why are you laughing how the internet
talks yeah okay what typeface is this
[Music]
with that asset yeah men just killing us
with the weird type is it what happens
is that
now I'm in doing yeah it looks like some
kind of random default typefaces it's
hurting me right now okay let's keep
gone this is a very similar layout to
something else that we saw right okay
okay and this one says comfort zone and
in the titles getting out of your
comfort zone I like that there's a
mixture of all caps and then all
lowercase so we're always looking for
contrast and that's a good use of
contrast and Emily tried to make this
all fit into the box and sometimes you
wind up with type that just doesn't line
up because it's not an even number so
this is a solution you add - in it it
works okay that's how you fill in the
space and sometimes you can come up with
some interesting layouts it's important
though it's important that you break it
up for the syllable yes so you know
where this is going now how do you read
this Kumpf or zone yeah yeah yeah see so
you should put it there
so then f would come back here and it
would just be just as good there's
really nothing like ones on the front
ones on the back right so if you had the
comfort here come fort so it would read
much better and so let's be mindful of
that okay hey guys hope you liked this
video we have more type posters to go
over with Emily but we're gonna do that
in another video make sure you like this
video subscribe to the channel and come
back next week for part two